[Music]
can you believe them all wanted me to
throw this away
not throwing this out no way man
oh wow the og hollywood bromance is on
full display
in georgia's hilarious new omaze
sweepstakes video
voice is 11. man brad's great in it too
is he man we just seen ocean 11 like 22
times
the premise what it would be like to
quarantine with clooney spoiler alert he
only has eyes for
one guy
he's so good he's just eating that's
all he just eats man he just eats you
brad man
it's just like he walks on the screen
and
wow now e.t has been tracking the
undeniable chemistry of this ocean's duo
for decades
i think we've been kind of a good couple
we'll bring out the best in each other
and we've seen firsthand brad can
certainly dish it back
i just stayed home i did a lot of
reading i bet we could find a picture of
you in there too
look what is that you have a question
george clooney i have a quick
impersonation
that you never know when a lifelong
friendship is gonna blossom but all the
pit punch lines are for a good cause
the winner will not only get an
all-expense-paid trip to hang with the
clooneys at their lake como home
but they'll also be supporting the
clooney foundation for justice
george told us getting to be able to
socialize again
is one of the bright sides to turning
60. you never look forward to 60.
the alternative is dead so i'll take it
but yeah
there is light at the end of this tunnel
and we're close to be in the same room
again
you